South Korea's government reportedly has
banned 36,000 foreigners from entering
the country for the Winter Olympics
because of security issues the games
officially start on Friday in one of the
most tense areas of the world just fifty
miles from the North Korean border Ben
Tracy is in the host city Pyongyang with
house security forces planned to keep
everyone safe Ben good morning good
morning so when Pyongyang was awarded
these games more than seven years ago
tensions in this region worked quite a
bit lower in North Korea did not have
nuclear weapons thought capable of
hitting the United States so a lot has
changed and now the security concerns
here involve everything from terrorism
to war a terrorist has taken athletes
hostage and is about to ram a vehicle
into an Olympic Stadium a chemical bomb
explodes in a trashcan as spectators run
for their lives in a drone carrying
explosives is shot out of the sky these
are just some of the terror drills
security forces have been conducting
near Olympic sites this law enforcement
command center is now open in
Pyeongchang to monitor security during
the games overall South Korea is
mobilizing a more than 60,000 person
Olympic security force including 50,000
soldiers that includes South Korean
Marines who in a somewhat odd display
with their American counterparts tested
their tolerance for the cold and snow
courage reconnaissance skills as well as
critical combat skills and a cold
weather mountainous environment of
course one of the biggest concerns is
North Korea
in 1987 10 months before South Korea
held the Summer Olympics in Seoul North
Korean agents placed a bomb on a Korean
Air flight killing all 115 people on
board Kim Jong Un's of rogue nation is
just 50 miles from Pyeongchang across
the demilitarized zone separating north
and south this is what is known as the
joint security area of the DMZ this is
where North and South meet you literally
have South Korean soldiers here who are
staring into North Korea which is just
beyond those blue Hut's the u.s. and
South Korea delayed their annual
military exercises so as not to provoke
North Korea the North's decision to send
a large delegation of the games he is
thought to have reduced the chances that
it will disrupt the event with a missile
launch or nuclear test another big
concern here at the Olympics is some
sort of large-scale cyber attack that
would disrupt the games and that is
something North Korea is particularly
adept at they have hired a private
security firm here to try to prevent
that kind of attack all right that's
good to hear thank you Ben Tracy